well the public sympathy is going to
reach a tipping point during these
strikes the previous industrial action
by doctors is unusual enough but one day
of industrial action by junior doctors
you know it's not long enough for
patients to begin to feel the effects
really but when you have talking about
45 days strikes you're going to see a
lot of operations council but it's going
to infuriate patients and their friends
and families and I mean one of the other
things that the doctors junior doctors
will find very hard to defend is this is
previously a deal but the BMA
recommended to its members can't really
be bad enough to justify 45 day strikes
I ain't one of the striking things about
it is that the junior doctors don't seem
to have an exit strategy I think it is
completely behind starting to think that
the government I'm going to offer any
concessions to do so in the face of such
militancy what would be to encourage you
know everyone else to behave in the same
way so I don't see how is you need not
going to back down but you already see
this you already see a big names in the
medical profession urging the junior
doctors not to go ahead with this strike
I'm in general ha well we'll wait and he
will wait because I think the government
think I think rightly that first of all
participation strikes is going to fall
right off I mean as you need up to see
the public opinion turning against them
and they begin to feel with the effects
of its industrial action in their own
pay packets in the right to Christmas I
think you will see people pulling back
from these strikes